let's see if we can calculate the volume
of this rectangular prism or i guess you
think this thing that's the shape of a
brick or a fish tank right over here and
what's interesting is now that the
dimensions are actually fractions we
have a width or we i guess yeah we could
call this the width the width here is
three-fifths of a unit the length here
is one and one-sixth units and the
height here is three-sevenths of a unit
so i encourage you to pause this video
and try to figure out the volume of this
figure on your own before we work
through it together
so there's a couple of ways to think
about it one way to think about it is
you're trying to pack unit cubes in here
and one way to think about how many unit
cubes could fit in here is to think
about the area is to think about the
area of this base right over here
so sometimes you'll see volume is equal
to the area of the base
times the height
times the height this right over here
is
the height and let me make it clear this
is the area of the base
area of the base times the height well
what's the area of the base
well the area of the base is the same
thing as the length times the width so
you might see it written like that you
might see it written as
area of base is going to be your is
going to be your length
times your width
width
length times width is the same thing as
your area of the base so that's that
right over there and of course you still
have to multiply times the height or
another way of thinking about it you're
going to multiply your length times your
width times your height you're going to
multiply the three dimensions of this
thing to figure out how many unit cubes
could fit into it to figure out the
volume so let's calculate it the volume
here is going to be what's our length
our length is 1 1 6 units
now when i multiply fractions as i'm
about to do i don't like to multiply
mixed numbers i like to write them as
improper fractions so let me convert 1
and 1 6 to an improper fraction
so 1 is the same thing as 6 6
plus 1 is 7 6.
so this is going to be 7 over 6 that's
my length
times three-fifths that's my width
so times
three fifths
times the height which is three
sevenths
times the height which is three sevenths
and we know when we multiply fractions
we can multiply the numerators
so it's going to be 7 times 3
times 3 times 3
and the denominator we can just multiply
the denominators so it's going to be
six
times five
six times five times seven
times seven
now we could just multiply these out but
just to try to get a an answer that has
a slightly lower that has a
as simplified as i can make it let me we
see we have a 7 in the numerator and a 7
in the denominator so let's divide the
numerator and the denominator by 7.
so let's divide the numerator
and the denominator by seven what that
does is that becomes one and those
become one
we also see what the numerator and
denominator has three they're both
divisible by three we see a three up
here we see a three over here so let's
divide both the numerator and the
denominator by 3.
so divide by 3 divide by 3. 3 divided by
3 is 1.
6 divided by 3 is going to be equal to
2.
so in our numerator what are we left
with
this is going to be equal to where we're
just left with that green three
it's going to be equal to three
over
two times five two times five is ten
two times five right over here so it's
going to the volume over here is three
tenths units cubed or we could fit three
tenths of a unit cube inside of this
brick or this fish tank or whatever you
want to call it